so two years ago you made a big change
and moved out here yeah this is kind of
like a popular fantasy of like oh I'm
gonna move out of the city I'm going to
move to the country I'm going to have
bees I saw bees over there I'm gonna
have a garden but for a lot of people
that would get tiring after six months
something like that how do you feel are
you happy about the move I'm absolutely
happy I feel calmer okay in my case it
happens
so gradually that you know when you boil
a frog and the Frog doesn't know that it
it will get boiled because the water
incrementally gets yeah that happened to
me just one day I realized that I live
here
who my life I love the nature and I love
to go Outdoors maybe that's why I feel
so comfortable here
so far the only person I've met in this
country found Happiness by getting away
from everyone else
I sympathize my inclination is almost
always to be left the hell alone
now we have to measure three liters of
water three liters yeah
two times
now we need to have patience and to wait
for it all right
my time in Gross devizi makes clear what
so many bulgarians left behind
let's hug it out Bulgarian
but if I want real insight into
Bulgarian sadness into my own sadness
I'll next need a translator who's fluent
in the language of misery
[Music]